921 مبنى سكنيا في عشر مدن جراء زلزال
ورغم الارهاق وقساوه الظروف الجويه يعكف
جيش من المتطوعين في اديمان على توفير
الطعام والدفء المتضررين من الزلزال
والعناصر الانقاذ والاغاثه على حد سواء
ذهبنا الى هذه الصور في وسط الطريق والتي
هي تعكس الواقع من
المتطوعين الذين يقومون في هذه الاثناء
وعلى مدار الايام بتحضير الشاي وايضا
القهوه للعاملين ولكل الذين يريدون او
يمرون في المدينه وكما ان نرى ايضا هنالك
مجموعه الان من الشبان الذين حضروا من عده
مناطق الى هذه المنطقه وهم الان مع ساعات
الفجر الاولى
منهم من يستريح ومنهم من كان في الورشه
ينتظر عينه او برهه من الوقت ثم بعد ذلك
ينتقل وايضا على جانب الطريق هذه الصور
لهذه الاواني التي يطبخ فيها كما نشاهد
الان وهي للشوربه الساخنه من هذه الجهه مع
البطاطا وايضا للشو العدس والتي تقدم منذ
عشره منذ سته سبعه ايام الى كل من يدخل
المدينه من اهلها او ابلا العاملين فيها
او من الذين ياتون من المناطق الاخرى
نشاهد ايضا الاستراحه للعمال الذين ياخذون
الان قسطا من الراحه بعد 24 ساعه وهذه
الخيام التي نراها وهذا المطبخ هو عباره
عن تقديم الطعام والدعم واللوجستي لكل
الفرق ولكل الذين يمرون على الطريق حتى ان
الخبز والفاكهه وكل الاحتياجات من بطاطا
بالاضافه الى مياه هذا المطبخ هو صوره
مصغره عن مئات المطابخ الموزعه والمنتشره
على طول المدينه والتي ايضا قامت بها
الاهليه وقامت بها الجمعيات المدنيه وقامت
ايضا بها الحكومه واذهب معك الى هذه
الصوره
المعبره جدا عن الالم لانتظار الذين تحت
الركاب لهذا العامل وايضا لاقاربه الذين
هم تحت الركب هو يوقد
بنا ناري ماء يمكن ان يساعده ويخفف عنه
هذا البرد بالاضافه الى انه يبيت في
العراق
فرق الانقاذ الرقم الصعب في معادله
الزلزال المدمره يعطون ظهورهم الكاميرات
لكن اعينهم تفتشوا عن كل خيط امل بين
الركام على مدار الساعه قصص تتحدث عن
معجزات حدثت بين شقوق المباني المدمره
التي تركها الزلزال نتابع
هنا يمكنك ان تلمس معجزات تنطق بها الارض
قالها فريق انقاذ الماني يعمل في تركيا
رابط انساني عجيب بين عمال الانقاذ وضحايا
الزلزال
دون ساعات طويله يتحدثون الى المنكوبين
يحاولون التخفيف من الامهم حينا واحيانا
كثيره يلقون اليهم باي وسيله ممكنه قد
تعيد اليهم الامل من جديد
زينب كرمان السيده التي خرجت على قيد
الحياه بعد اربع ساعات تحدت خلالها البرد
وانعدام اسباب الحياه بعد يوم من انقاذها
تلقت فرق الانقاذ خبر وفاتها
التزموا الصمت دعوه يكررها المنقذون
للمتجمهرين حول حطام المباني لعلهم يدركون
استغاثه ناج هنا او هناك
وخلال احدى لحظات الصمت تلك تحديدا في
قهرمان مرعش انتبه عمال الانقاذ لمعجزه
جديده
عائشه الطفله ذات السبعه اعوام خاضت صراعا
طويلا لمده سته ايام وسط امل وخوف اطبق
على المكان لساعات طويله لتولد من جديد
التشبث بالحياه رساله يواصل كتابه سطورها
من هم تحت الانقاض فهذا الرضيع الذي يبلغ
من العمر شهرين خرج حيا وسط الذهول كل من
يتابع المشهد
سيد الحديدي العربيه
الله اكبر
ان شاء الله
التركيه زيدان العربيه اهلا بك زيدان كيف
هي الاوضاع في هذه البلده هل تبدو احسن
حالا من بقيه مناطق غازي عنتاب وهل انقطعت
الامال في العثور على ناجين
على انتشار الجثث من تحت الانقاض
نعم بلده نوردار ليست افضل حالا مثلا من
بلده اصلاحيه التي زرناها قبل قليل ويوم
امس بلده نورداغ ايضا هي من المناطق
المتضرره بشده في ولايه غازي عنتاب
التركيه هذه البلده كانت في اليوم الاول
مركز الحدث عندما كانت مركز اقوى الهزات
الارتداديه حتى الان التي شهدتها البلاد
على اثر الزلزال اقوى هزه ارتداديه كانت
6.6 كانت هنا في بلده نوردار حيث ادت او
ادت ادت الزلازل العنيفه وقبل ان انتقل
الى هذه المركز الانقاذ ساطلب من زميلي في
حال استطاع الوصول الى الطريق السريع هناك
في سفح هذا الجبل هذا الطريق السريع الذي
يربط كل المدن الجنوبيه ديار بكر ماردين
شارلي اورفا غازي عنتاب كهرمان مرعش
عثمانيه واضنه بانقره واسطنبول هذا الطريق
السريع نتيجه الزلازل التي حدثت حدثت
والهزات الارتداديه تضرر بشكل كبير وتوقف
وادى توقف هذا
الطريق السريع الى تاخر وصول المساعدات
واللجوء السلطات التركيه الى طرق بديله
ايضا اخرت وصول المساعدات نعود الى هذا
الموقع الذي نتواجد فيه هنا ساطلب من زميل
ان ينقل الكاميرا
والعدسه حتى يستطيع مشاهدي العربيه حتى
يستطيع المشاهدون العربيه متابعه ما يجري
نعم فرق الانقاذ ما تزال تواصل العمل على
اخراج الناجين اليوم السابع دخل قبل ساعات
من على وقوع الكارثه لكن حتى الان
الاعمال لا تزال موجوده هناك في بعض
المواقع
فرق الانقاذ ما تزال تحاول الوصول الى
ناجين هناك معجزات تحدث انباء من كهرمان
مرعش ومن هاتاي اشخاص صمدوا لاكثر من 150
ساعه هذه الاخبار تشجع فرق الانقاذ على
مواصله البحث في المناطق التي يعتقدون ان
هناك اشخاص ما زالوا على قيد الحياه طبعا
الجيش التركي دخل في بعض المواقع كما في
مدينه اصلاحيه هناك تقريبا الجيش التركي
انتشر في هذه المدينه وفرق الجيش التركي
المتخصصه تشارك فرق افاد والمتطوعين
والفرق الاجنبيه في محاولات البحث
والانقاذ طبعا هناك مواقع عديده شاهدناها
تمت انتهاء من البحث عمليات البحث
والانقاذ والان الجرافات تقوم بازاله
الركام والانقاض لكن في هذا الموقع الذي
نتواجد امامه الان العمليات ما تزال
مستمره كما تشاهدون الى جوار هذا الموقع
المباني متصدعه بالك هذه هذه المباني
متصدعه بالكامل غير صالحه للسكن بحاجه الى
هدم واعاده ترميم هذا الشارع كل كل هذا
الشارع الان سنحاول ان ننصر لكم المشهد كل
هذا الشارع تقريبا فيه دمار على طول هذا
الشهر هذا الشارع الذي نتواجد فيه الان هو
الطريق القديم ما بين ولايه غازي عنتاب
وعثمان واضنه
نعم لذلك نشهد ازدحاما في هذا الشارع على
طول امتداد هذا الشارع وهو ايضا يمر من
وسط نورداك طول امتداد هذا الشارع الدمار
موجود والابنيه المتصدعه كما نشاهد واجهات
الانبياء
المتصدعه ومتشكله من خطر ايضا على
المنقذين وعلى السكان الذين يرغب بعضهم في
العوده لهذه المباني
لا شك ان المتطوعين يعملون بظروف خطره جدا
للغايه يعني في كل المواقع التي كنا فيها
ان كان في اضنه او في غازي عنتاب هنا في
نورداغ او حتى يوم امس في اصلاحيه كل
المباني التي يعملون بها بجوارها مباني
متصدعه لذلك العمليه تكون بشكل دقيق وهناك
في بعض المناطق في عده مناطق سواء في او
في الولايات العشر هناك بعض المواقع شهدت
انهيارات جزئيه من المباني المجاوره قرب
فرق الانقاذ وفي بعض الحالات ادت الى
اصابات لكن الحمد لله كانت اصابات طفيفه
بالعموم وضع خطر جدا المباني التي نشاهدها
الان غير صالحه للسكن وبالتالي ممنوع على
سكانها العوده الى هذه المباني لكن هناك
مشكله ايضا مع وجود هذا هذه التصدعات
وتشققات الكبيره هناك مشكله في الهزات
الارتداديه التي تثير قلق السلطات التركيه
اكثر من غيرها اي هزه قد تؤدي الى انهيار
مبنى او اثنين او ثلاثه لذلك حتى الان
مشكله المباني المدمره وعددها حتى الان
اقترب من 25 الف بحسب ما ذكرت بعض وسائل
الاعلام التركيه هي ليست المشكله الوحيده
انما المباني المتصدعه الاله للانهيار هي
المشكله الاكبر
هناك جهد كبير مطلوب من السلطات التركيه
بعد الانتهاء من ازاله الانقاض في التعامل
مع هذا الموضوع
اما ترميم المباني التي تصلح للسكن او
التي يمكن في حال اعاده تاهيلها وترميمها
ان تصلح للسكن او هدم المباني المتصدعه
بشكل كبير وبناء مباني جديده الحاله
الامنيه زيدان هل تشكل هاجسا كبيره
بالنسبه للسلطات في هذه المناطق متظاهره
في تركيا
نعم هناك مشكله برزت خلال ايام الاخيره
وهي موضوع حدوث بعض عمليات السلب والنهب
في بعض المناطق لذلك نعم هناك انتشار كبير
للجيش طبعا بما انه هناك حاله طوارئ
فالجيش انتشر في بعض المناطق او بدا ينتشر
تباعا في مدينه اصلاح اصلاحيه انتشر بشكل
كبير يعني يوم امس وصلت تعزيزات كبيره
تقريبا في كل الشوارع الرئيسيه وحتى
الشوارع الفرعيه كان هناك انتشار للجيش
هذا هناك محاوله لضبط هذه الامور يوم امس
ايضا السلطات التركيه اوقفت 48 شخصا كانوا
متهمين بمحاوله سلب ونهب بعض المنازل
المهجوره والتي تركها اهلها وذهبوا الى
مراكز ايواء مؤقته او غادروا الولايه الى
مناطق اخرى
طيب مراكز الايواء المؤقته هذه بالتاكيد
لن تكون بديلا عن المنازل باي شكل من
الاشكال لكن الى اي مدى حسب مشاهدتك زيدان
هي مهيئه لتوفير سبل الراحه المتضررين
نعم لا شك المراكز الايواء المؤقته
الحاليه تنقسم الى قسمين الاول وهو سكن
الطلابي في الجامعات الحكوميه وايضا
الجامعات بعد الجامعات والمدارس
والمدارس وبعض المؤسسات الحكوميه الشطر
الثاني او القسم الثاني وهو الخيام لا شك
ان الخيام هي اكثر سوءا من مراكز الايواء
الاخرى لان الخيام نعم تزود ببعض الخيام
او قسم كبير من الخيام يزود بوسائل تدفئه
والان الان الان يطلبون الصمت سنحاول
العوده الى الموقع اطلب من زميلي العوده
الى الموقع فريق الانقاذ يطلب الصمت نعم
ايقاف الطريق
الى انتهاء مرحله الصمت دعني اذكر
المشاهدين بان الان نواصل متابعه عمل عمال
انقاذ من بلده نورداغ في غازي عنتاب
التركيه حيث تتواصل عمليه البحث عن ناجين
بين الانقاض عقب هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا يوم الاثنين
الماضي بشده سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه
مشاهدينا ونتحدث عن تركيا وسوريا يعيشان
الماساه في يومها السابع وسط امال ضئيله
في العثور عن ناجين الحصيه الاجماليه حتى
الان لعدد القتلى في البلدين تجاوزت 30
قتيلا وفق حصيله جديده ثلاث عفوا 30 الف
قتيل وفق حصيله جديده غير نهائيه ونذكر
ايضا ان منظمه الصحه العالميه اكدت ان 26
مليون شخص تاثروا بحد زلزال في كل من
سوريا وتركيا فيما قدرت الامم المتحده
مشاهدينا ان عدد القتلى سيتجاوز اربعين
الفا واكد ان مرحله الانقاذ في تركيا
اقتربت من نهايتها كما شاهد مشاهدين ايضا
في هذه الاخبار العاجله فرقه الانقاذ في
غازي عنتاب التواصل عملياتها املا في
العثور على نجيم تحدث ايضا مراسله العربيه
قبل قليل عن هزه ارتداديه ضربت اغازي
عنتاب ايضا اليوم والان
تجري لحظه الصمت بطلب من فرق الانقاذ
في محيط هذه المنطقه او هذا المبنى الذي
يتم فيها البحث عن ناجين لحظه اسطمت هذه
هي
من اجل محاوله السماع اي اصوات
لنا جيم من تحت هذه الانقاض في محاوله
انقاذهم بالتاكيد
ثم بعد ذلك تتواصل عمليات البحث مره اخرى
بعد انتهاء فتره الصمت هذه السلطات
التركيه مشاهدينا على الرئيس التركي اعلنت
ارتفاع عدد القتله الى خمسه
الف قتيل ويقارب 25,000 هو عدد الجرحى
ايضا الى نحو 80 الفا ومئتين
وثمانيه وسبعين جريحا بحسب وزير الصحه ولم
تخفي طبعا السلطات في تركيا تخوفها من
احتمالات انتشار الاوبئه واكدت ايضا انها
تتخذ جميع التدابير اللازمه لمواجهه ذلك
هناك ايضا حديث لوسايا اعلام التركيه
يتحدث فيه اليوم عن انهيار وتضرر قرابه 25
الف مبنى في العديد من المدن لكنها حذرت
من هذا من ان هذا هذا العدد قابل للارتفاع
بسبب الانهيارات التي تحدث بسبب الهزه
الارشداديه نعود مره اخرى الى مراسلنا
زيدان كلو في بلده نورداغ في غاز مرحبا بك
زيدان من جديد هل انتهت فتره الصمت اذا
نعم انتهت فتره الصمت وطلب من الجميع
التحرك
توقف السعر كما ذكرت لكم ان هذا الطريق هو
الطريق الحالي اللي هو الطريق البديل
والطريق القديم
الذي يربط بين غازي عنتاب وعثمانيا
الان تحرك السير مجددا بعد انتهاء فتره
الصمت وكما نشاهد يعني حقيقه العمل صعب
ومربك لاسيما عندما يكون في هذه المناطق
يتوقف السير بين ولايتين وبالتالي العمليه
صعبه يعني وتطلب جهود وكما نلاحظ هذه
العمليه تتطلب مشاركه رجال الشرطه وشرطه
السير وايضا عناصر امنيه موجوده في المكان
لذلك كما ذكرنا عمليه الانقاذ ستتواصل بما
انه طلبوا لحظه صمت ما زال هناك امل طالما
ان انهم يحاولون الوصول الى ناجين ما زال
هناك امل وان شاء الله تتكلم هذه الجهود
النجاح في هذا الموقع وفي مواقع اخرى ان
كان في غازي عنتاب او في بقيه الولايات
الاخرى طيب زيدان ذكرتك انا غازي عنتاب
تعاني من النقص في الخيم وايضا وفي
المساعدات الانسانيه هل يعد ذلك الى تضرر
الطرق
المؤديه الى هذه المنطقه
اعتقد ان الموضوع مرتبط
بشكل اساسي باتساع رقعه المناطق المتضرره
يعني اليوم المساعدات يجب ان توزع الى عشر
ولايات طبعا هناك اولويات بعض الولايات
مدمره بشكل اكبر من ولايات اخرى لكن اليوم
نتحدث عن 13 مليون شخص متضرر بشكل مباشر
من هذه من هذا الزلزال وعشرين مليون بشكل
غير مباشر يعني المجموعه العام لعدد
المتضررين بين بشكل مباشر وشكل غير مباشر
20 مليون وبالتالي وصول المساعدات الى
الاشخاص الاكثر حاجه يتطلب مزيد من
المساعدات مزيد من الدعم المقدم سواء من
المنظمات التركيه او من الدول التي تعهدت
في تقديم مساعدات هذا الموضوع ايضا يتطلب
وقت هذا الوقت مع الاسف ليس في صالح
الاهالي الذين يقيم بعضهم في مناطق بارده
واساسا الطقس في هذه الايام منذ حدوث
الزلزال وحتى الان هو طقس بارد جدا في
غازي عنتاب الحراره دائما تحت الصفر وهذه
ايضا مشكله كبيره يعاني منها الجميع
شكرا لك من بلده نورداغ في غاز عنتاب
التركيه كنت مع زيدان العربيه تحياتي زي
اعلن رئيس قسم الحد من المخاطر باداره
الطوارئ والكوارث في تركيا اورخانتيتار
اعلن ان زلزال الذي ضرب البلاد في السادس
من فبراير استمر لدقيقتين وعادل من وجهه
النظر العلميه انفجار 500 قنبله ذريه هذا
وقالت اداره الكوارث التركيه ان اكثر من
1891 هزرت ارتداديه تم تسجيلها منذ
الاثنين الماضي
ومشاهدينا نتابع الان هذه الصور المباشره
من منطقه اصلاحيه في تركيا ومشاهد في حجم
الدمار الكبير من السيارات ولي ايضا
المباني وبعض المار ايضا في هذه المنطقه
وعمال الانقاذ وهم يسعون للبحث عن ناجين
بين انقاذ هذه المباني في منطقه اصلاحيه
التي ايضا تعرضت لهذا الزلزال الكبير ضرب
جنوب تركيا وضرب ايضا مناطق في شمال غرب
سوريا يوم الاثنين الماضي بالعوده
مشاهدينا الى الاسياخ تغطيتنا انتشرت في
وسائل الاعلام التركيه مقطع انتشر مقطع
فيديو لصدع احدثه الزلزال وسط حقل زيتون
في تركيا ويقدر عرض الصدع بحوالي 200 متر
وعمقه ب 30 مترا في مشهد يصف قوه الزلزال
الذي ضرب المنطقه التي تبعد اكثر من 100
كيلومتر عن مركز الهزه
ربما هدات بعض النفوس الان لكن لحظه التي
ضرب فيها
ستبقى في قلوب منعايشوها هذا فيديو متداول
لتلك اللحظه الاولى قبل سته ايام نشاهد
قد ينتظر هؤلاء الى اجل غير مسمى فهذه
الوقفه وان طالت وسببت خضرا والما وهذه
الوجوه التي تترقب يبقى وجعها اخف وطاه من
هذه الوقفه حيث لا امل باق فقد وصل النبا
الذي لا يريد احد سماعه في هذه الفوضى
البحث جار عن صوت ضعيف يعلن عن حياه لم
يبقى امامها الكثير
يبقى صوت هذه الجرافات التي تحرك حجرا
ربما يكشف عن ابن او اخ او امن او اب
افضل من صوت تلك التي تعلن النهايه
مشاهدينا من عمان ينضم الى الدكتور محمد
محمود القريوتي الباحث هو المختص في علمي
دكتور محمود معنا في هذه التغطيه كما
تبعنا هذه
التصدعات الكبيره في مناطق مختلفه من
الاراضي التركيه بعد هذا الزلزال كيف يمكن
تفسيرها علميا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم صباح الخير لك
وللساده المشاهدين وشكرا على الاستضافه
اسال الله تعالى ان يرحم من تضع وان يشافي
الجرحى والمصابين اخي الكريم يعني نحن
امام حقيقه
حدث زلزالي وعاصفه زلزاليه قويه
ودمارها وتاثيرها حقيقه واسع طبعا تفسير
ما حدث من هذه الصدوع هو الحركه الحركه
على الصفحتين الصفيحه العربيه والصفيحه
صفيحه الاناضول طبعا الحركه عنيفه احدثت
نشاطا زكزاليا كبيرا رافق هذا النشاط هذا
هذا هذه التصدعات الكبيره حقيقه وهذا ليس
ليس غريبا
فالحركه حقيقه تعتبر نوع القوي والعالي
فيمكن ان تحدث هذه التصدعات طبعا هذه
التصدعات التي على السطح لكن هي تغوص في
الاعماق عده او عشرات من الكيلومترات لكن
ما ظهر هو هو على السطح تكسرات عنيفه
وذلك لهذه الحركه طبعا طبعا سبب هذه
التكسرات كما ذكرت على الصفحتين هي الضغوط
التي تراكمت عبر الزمن
وهذه الضغوط عندما تتراكم وتصبح بشكل لا
يتحمل السطر فيحدث الكسر وتتحرر الطاقه من
تلك المنطقه نحن نتحدث عن صدع بعرض 200
متر وعمق 30 مترا وهي ارقام ليست بالقليله
يعني هل يمكن ان يستمر ذلك او هذه الارقام
في الارتفاع هذا العمق وهذا العرض
طبعا ما ظهره على السطح كما ذكرت لك يعني
التكسرات التي ظهرت على السطح لكن هذا
السطح طويل الذي حدث عليه الحركه في حدود
100كم لكن ما ظهر على السطح هو هو كما
ذكرت طبعا غالبا
غالبا الزلزال الرئيسي حدث وهذا حدث عليه
هذه التكسرات
تكسرات قد تكون توقفت لان النشاط او شده
هذا النشاط كانت في قوته فالان
العاصفه تبدا او بدات حقيقه في
ان تقل حدتها بحيث ان الزلازل الكبيره تقل
شيئا فشيئا كما لاحظنا بدايه العاصفه كان
هناك عده زلازل تفوق السته درجات تقريبا
من سته الى سبع درجات بعد يومين او ثلاث
قل ذلك بحيث ان ظهر الان ان زلزال قوه سته
مع الزمن اعتقد سوف يقل شيئا فشيئا
يعني يستمر النشاط في حدود اقل من ذلك
ممكن في حدود الخمسه او خمسه ونص او اقل
الى فتره طبعا هذا قد يستمر الى عده
اسابيع لكن بعد ذلك
يقل شيئا فشيئا لكن العاصفه سوف تستمر
لاسابيع وربما اشوى طبعا عندما اقول تستمر
ليس بمعنى ذلك ان الزلازل سوف تستمر او
الاحساس بها سوف يستمر فقد يقل شيئا فشيئا
الى ان نصل الى مرحله
تكون فيها الزلازل تسجل فقط على محطات
الزلازل يمكن ان لا يتم الشعور فيها فلذلك
فلذلك تكون يعني التكرار
تدريجيا طيب هل من وسيله التعامل مع هذه
التصدعات وتقليل خطرها ايضا على المناطق
التي ظهرت فيها وهل يمكن ان يشكل ذلك
تمهيدا لتغيرات
جيولوجيه وجغرافيه في هذه الم ايضا
يعني ما حدث حدث
التكسرات حدثت وكما ذكرت التكسرات العنيفه
تكون على نشاطات كبيره يعني السبعه ونص
ثمانيه وكذا فحدث ما حدث من هذا التكسرات
ولا اعتقد ان تحدث تكسرات خلال هذه
العاصفه
قد يحدث نشاط اخر لكن بعيد عن هذه المنطقه
وذلك حتى تعود الصفائح الى الى الى وضع
الاستقرار فبالتالي ما حدث في المنطقه
مستبعد ان يستمر اي اي تشققات او اي
تصدعات دكتور محمود في تقديرك يعني ما هي
الدروس التي يمكن لتركيا ان تستلهمها من
هذه التجربه القاسيه
يعني يعني حقيقه نحن امام امام تجربه كما
ذكرت قاسيه وقاسيه جدا
لكن لكن مع الالم طبعا على الضحايا
والمصابين لكن هناك حقيقه دروس كثيره جدا
يعني من هذه الدروس طبعا ما هو شاهد
العيان كيف راينا الابنيه تنهار مباشره
وهناك ملاحظه اخرى قد نرى بعض الابنيه
تنهار تماما لكن بجانبها بعض الابنيه لم
يصبها ضرر معنى ذلك الخلل في المبنى الخلل
في المبنى طبعا
الامور الاخرى هو هو حقيقه بما انه التنبؤ
توقع بالزلازل وقتا وتاريخا غير غير وارد
فالافضل او الطريقه المثلى في ذلك هو
تقييم الخطر الزلزالي انا بصدد نشاط
زلزالي لا يمكن لا يمكن ان ان استطيع ان
اوقف هذا النشاط
فالطريقه المثلى هو هذا الخطا الخطر حاسب
وحاسب يتم تقييم هذا وهذا ممكن وهذا ما
يحصل على مناطق كثيره من من المناطق
الزلزاليه واعتقد اعتقد في تركيا يعني هم
يعني ماشيين في هذا في هذا في هذا المسار
بحيث يتم تقييم وبعد التقييم وبعد التقييم
يتم معرفه ما هو لدينا من من مباني ومنشات
وتجمعات سكانيه بحيث عمل خرائط يتم فيها
معرفه وبهذا المناطق تقليل المخاطر
الكبيره في اي مستقبليه لا سمح الله اعتذر
منك هذا ما سمح به الوقت شكرا لك من عمان
كنت معنا دكتور محمود القريوتي الباحث هو
المختص في علمي
متابعين المشاهدين هذه الصور المباشره
بمنطقه اصلاحيه في تركيا
انقاذ ما زالوا يحاولون البحث عن ناجم بين
انقاذ هذه المبانية تضررت بفعل هذا الجزار
الكبير التي ضرب هذه المنطقه وجنوب تركيا
وشمال غرب سوريا يوم الاثنين الماضي كما
ذكرنا مشاهدينا فان البلدين يعيشان هذه
الماساه في يومها السابع وسط امال ضئيله
في العثور على الناجين السلطات التركيه
كانت اعلنت اليوم على لسان نائب الرئيس
التركي ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى نحو 25 الف
قتيل الجرحى الى
نحو ثمانين الف جريح بحسب وزير الصحه
التركيه
مشاهدينا مع بدء عمليه التوقيف عدد من
المقاولين الاتراك المسؤولين عن تشييد
المباني في المناطق الاكثر تضررا عبر
الكثير من الاهالي عن غضبهم من شركات
المقاولات التي كلفت بانشاء مجمعات
السكنيه التي انهارت في ثوان معدودات
ثلاثه من احفادي ابنتي وزوجها خمسه اشخاص
وانا في الانتظار
شركه البناء القت بقطع خرسانيه لتراعي
شروط البناء الانشاءات لم تكن تحت اشراف
الدوله فمت الكثير من الناس بسبب عدم وجود
رقبه
لا يوجد شيء الخرسانه مليئه بالرمل هذه
المباني انهارت في اول ثوان من الزلزال
ربما نجا ثلاثه اشخاص فقط من مبنى واحد
بينما قتل اكثر من 100 شخص
الزمان اغسطس
1999 المكان ولايه
بتركيا الحدث زلزال بقوه سبع درجات فاصله
سته على مقياس ريختر هز البلاد 45 ثانيه
خلفت اكثر من 17 الف قتيل وما يقدر بنحو
500 الف شخص
اجراءات كثيره اتخذت لتفادي تكرار الكابوس
في بلد اراد قدره الجغرافي ان يكون بلد
الزلازل قوانين ولوائح بناء جديده ابرزها
فرض تحديث البنيه التحتيه لتكون اكثر
مقاومه للزلازل وفرض ضريبه الزلزال
للاستعداد للاسوء لكن اليوم وبعدما تكرر
السيناريو اصوات تتساءل عن اموال ضريبه
الزلازل وفيما استثمرت ينتقدون عفوا عن
البناء غير القانوني مقابل دفع غرامه
محدده
قدمته الحكومه التركيه
اتهامات بالمقابل تطالب البلديات
والمقاولين بالاهمال القاتل السلطات لاحقت
واعتقلت العشرات من المقاولين بعد الزلزال
ومنعت اخرين من السفر
للتحقيق معهم
الزلزال قطع العديد من الطرقات السريعه
والفرعيه جنوب البلاد
اغلق مطارها طاي اكثر المطارات حيويه في
المنطقه
الاضرار تسببت بتاخر الفرق لانقاذ
والمساعدات للمدن المتضرره الزلزال اضر
بخطوط الغاز والنفط وفاقم معاناه
المنكوبين في الشتاء
اتخذت اجراءات لتفريغ السدود من المياه
خوفا من انهيارها
الاحصائيات تشير الى خسائر بمليارات
الدولارات في البنى التحتيه
في سوريا المجاوره افادت تقديرات المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان مقتل خمسه الاف
ومئتي على الاقل في زلزال وبخلاف تركيا
التي تصلها المساعده الدوريه من كل مكان
يواجه مانكبوز الزهري في سوريا خطرا
مضاعفا مع استمرار الجدل حول مساله فتح
المعابر وشروط الوصول الى المتضررين في
منطقه شمال سوريا حيث تسيطر المعارضه على
هذه المناطق هنا يبرز ملف العقوبات على
النظام السوري ومطالب دمشق بضروره وقف هذه
العقوبات حتى تتيسر عمليه الاغاثه في
المناطق المنكوبه احدث التصريحات جاءت على
لسان مبعوث الاتحاد الاوروبي الى سوريا
الذي دعا دمشق لعدم تاسيس قضيه المساعدات
الانسانيه
مبعوث الاتحاد الاوروبي الى سوريا
دانستونيسكو رفض في الوقت ذاته اتهام
الاتحاد الاوروبي بعدم تقديم ما يكفي من
المساعدات السوريين مضيفا بان التكتل
الاوروبي يقدم المساعدات الى سوريا منذ
اكثر من عشر سنوات بل ويقدم المزيد خلال
ازمه الزلزال الحاليه وفق تعبيره
في غضون ذلك اكد المرصد الى العربي انه لا
يمكن احصاء عدل المفقودين جراء الزلزال
لكن عددهم كبير جدا واضاف ان محدوديه
امكانيه الامكانيات تسببت في فشل انقاذ
احياء حوصر تحت الانقاض ولقوا حتفهم ولفت
الى صعوبه دخول المساعدات الى المناطق
المذكور بزلزال حيث لم يتم تسجيل دخول سوى
المساعدات السعوديه
ما تزال قصه رضيعه التي وردت تحت الانقاذ
بدت جنديرس شمال سوريا ولقبت بعنقائد
زلزال ما تزال تحظى باهتمام وسط اخبار
الموت التي خلفها زلزال المدمر كميا
العربيه رافقت منقذها الذي زارها في
المستشفى استعداد لنقلها الى بيت خلال
الايام القادمه جديد القصه في متابعه
مستمره للزميل عبد القادر خربوش
يحدوه امل في ان يجد عنقاء الزلزال في صحه
جيده حيث تقضي ايام حياتها الاولى بهذا
المشفى بعفرين رفقه ابنه جرى اول لقاء
لهما بها بعيدا عن الدمار واهوال الزلزال
سعاده تشاركها مع زوجته التي شاءت الاقدار
ان تضع هي الاخرى مولودتها تزامنا مع
الولاده العجيبه لهذه الرضيعه فقرر ان
يمنحها اسما ويتكفل برعايتها الى جانب
ابنتهما طلب مني حموده ابني قال لي سميها
عفراء على اسم خالتي
فسمعتها عفر على اسم امها من ساعتها انه
ابوها راح وامها واخواتها ضلت هي ذكرى
البنت عندي من اهلها صارت وحده من اولادي
يعني ما راح ان شاء الله ما راح اميزها هي
من اولادي يعني وراح تكون اغلى من اولادي
ان شاء الله زاد
لا يكاد خليل يستوعبوا كيف تشبثت عفراء
بالحياه واصطدمار اودى بحياه كل افراد
عائلتها والاف عجزت اجسادهم عن مقاومه هول
زلزال لم يبقي ولم يذر برضينا الله يرحمه
عائلته كانوا ولد عمي يعني واقرب الناس
الي وكان اكثر من اخ لالي هو وكان المقرب
لالي اكثر شيء هو فراحت عيلته كلياتها
زوجته واطفاله واخته فما ظل احدهم غير
البنت ذكرى من عنده فبدي ربيها انا وراح
تظل هاي ذكرى للابد
قصته مع عفراء تعيده الى المكان الذي قطع
فيه حبلها السريه من والدتها ونجح في
اخراجها من تحت هذه الانقاض لتصبح عنوان
امل يحفظ في ذاكره الملايين عن الكارثه
لا يتصور العقل ولا يعني شي فوق الخيال
نصل الساعه اربعه نشتغل جبنا اليات بلشنا
للساعه 2:00 لقينا الطفله هاي تقريبا
وبقدر ما لاقت قصه ولاده الرضيعه تفاعلا
واسعا شكلت بالنسبه لمنقذها خليل منعرجا
حاسما في حياته وسيكون يوم اخراجها من
المشفى ونقلها الى بيته بدايه جديده لفصول
قصه جميله اختصرت مشهد الموت والحياه عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه
البريطانيه معنا مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن اهلا بك سيدي
رامي معنا في هذه التغطيه كما تابعنا فان
هناك اتهامات متبادله بين النظام السوري
والمجتمع الدولي بشان بوصول المساعده الى
المتضررين بحسب متابعتكم سيد رامي على
الارض هل تقف العقوبات الغربيه عائقا
ومعاركرا حقيقيا امام وصول هذه المساعدات
الى المتضررين في سوريا نعم صباح الخير
طبعا
الرضيعه او الطفله هي تعطي الامل للشعب
السوري حقيقه الامر ما جاء في التقرير قبل
ان نبدا في العقوبات العقوبات اذا كانت هي
عائق لماذا وصلت المساعدات نحو 60 طائره
باعتراف النظام من الدول العربيه وغير
عربيه وصلت الى مطارات النظام وكان فيها
مساعدات وفرق فاز والى اخره لو كان هناك
العقوبات الدوليه تعيق لما وصلت هذه
المساعدات ولكن هل تصل المساعدات الى
مستحقيها بالفعل وان كانت المساعدات تصل
الى مستحقيها لماذا هناك الان تكافل اهلي
كبير شاهدناه في الاراضي السوريه من اجل
جمع مساعدات وارسالها الى مستحقيها من
كامل التراب السوري من اقصى الجنوب من
محافظه السويداء من اقصى الشمال من محافظه
الحسكه شمال الشرقي
جميع التراب السوريه لذلك اقول المشكله في
توزيع المساعدات طريق التوزيع المستعده
مساعدات الى مستحقيها قبل ان نقول ان
العقوبات الدوليه هي عائق مثل ما طالب
بشار الاسد في وصول المساعدات الى ابناء
الشعب السوري المساعدات تصل وهي تصل
بالشكل المستمر حتى يا سيدي الكريم من
ليبيا وصلت من مناطق شرق ليبيا مساعدات
وطائرات الى ابناء الشعب السوري من تونس
بكل من الجزائر من الدول العربيه وصلت
مساعدات الان المطلوب ان يكون هناك اهليه
لتوزيع المساعدات على مستحقيها بعد انقضاء
بالعثور على ناجين او احياء تحت الانقاذ
الان الامل بابقاء من نجى على قيد الحياه
وليس بحياه الذل يعني كما يفعل البعض ولكن
ايضا ان نساعد بعدم سرقه المساعدات مثل ما
يجري في تركيا سرقت المنازل المقدمه في
سوريا تشرف المساعدات التي من المفترض ان
تكون لناس محتاجين وهم بامس الحاجه اليها
تفضل حتى اطباء بين حدود ذكرت ان النظام
السوريه يمنعها من دخول اراضيه هل تاكدت
لكم هذه المعلومه ولماذا يفعل النظام ذلك
موقف سياسي بالاطباء بلا حدود لانها كانت
تساعد مناطق المعارضه وهو يعتبر النظام
السوري ان منصره الاطباء بلا حدود لديها
اجنده دوريه وترتبط باجهزه المخابرات
الغربيه مثلما يكون على المقصد لذلك اقول
النظام يتخذ رائع من يريد الان مساعدات
يجب ان لا يكون هذه منظمه عميله للمخابرات
الغربيه
هو اشترط على مناطق الاداره الذاتيه او
الهلال الاحمر الكردي اذا ما اراد ادخال
المساعدات الى داخل احياء مدينه حلب ان
يصادر النظام ان يحصل النظام على نصف هذه
المساعدات هل ترى ان هناك اجرام واجرام
بحق المحتاجين اكثر من هذا الاشعار انت
كيف تشترك على المقدمين مساعدات ان تاخذ
يوسف هذه المساعدات باي قانون تشترط يعني
اذا ما كانت فصيل الجيش الوطني حاول سرقه
نصف المساعدات في عفرين فبشار الاسد يعتبر
نفسه نظام ودوله كيف تريد ان تحصل على نصف
المساعدات للنظام
هل النظام حلفاء ربما شجعوا ذلك على اتخاذ
هذه الخطوه بدائل
لهذه المنظمات الدوليه ماذا عن حلفاء
النظام هل سجلت لهم ايضا مشاركات في
عمليات الانقاذ في هذه المناطق المتضرره
الواقع سجل تواجد الايرانيين حق الثور
الايراني
في البدايه وهذا كنا ما نخشاه ان يستغل
هؤلاء ماثاه الشعب السوري ويظهر بانهم
منفذين الشعب السوري ولكن لاحقا المساعدات
العربيه من الامارات العربيه المتحده من
الجزائر من مصر والعرب الذين كانوا
موجودين بالنسبه للشعب السوري كان وجودهم
اهم من وجود الايرانيين وحلفاء النظام
السياسيين الذين ساهموا بقتل ابناء الشعب
السوري
انتشال الجثث الان في
مناطق المعارضه هو الاولويه الان هل
انقطعت كل الامال في العثور على الناجين
وذلك طبعا الى شكل المعدات ونوعيه المعدات
المتوفره ايضا لفرق الانقاذ هناك نعم نعم
من المعدات هي كانت الاهم لم تدخل المعدات
ولم تدخل هناك فرق انقاذ يعني لديها قبرات
اكثر من طرف الدفاع المدني وايضا لم تدخل
على سبيل المثال شاهدنا الكلاب في تركيا
هي
تساعد لكن بسوريا لا يوجد لديك امكانيات
فتوقف العمل عن البحث عن الناجحين الان
البحث عن طريقه انتشار الجثث من تحت انقاذ
المباني التي تهدمت على رؤوس قاتليها
ونعيد ونسكر من جنديرس لماذا لان الكارثه
الكبرى كانت في هذه البلده الصغيره التي
تهدم فيها عشرات المنازل لنقل مئات
المنازل الكثير منها بات مهدم بشكل كامل
وهذه المنطقه يوجد تحت انقاضها المزيد من
الجلسرين ولكن نعود الى مناطق النظام
عندما كان يضحك بشار الاسد كان بالقرب منه
لا يزال من هم تحت الارض كان ينتظرون
اخراجهم من تحت الانقاذ ان لم يكونوا الان
قد صارحوا الحياه شكرا لكم البريطاني كنت
معنا مديرا مرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
رابع عبد الرحمن تحياتي
مستويه
وصار هالشي هذا اللي راح ابنه واللي راح
ابنته واللي راحت عيلته اول مره بتصير هيك
بهالفجعه هيك بهاللي انا
ما مر علي هيك والله اي حركه عم نحس دائما
في تشقق بالبيت صار فيه يعني ريان بالبيت
يعني
فاضطريت الجا للجامعه
تعد المعابر الحدوديه بين تركيا وسوريا
فوق النجاه الاخير للناجين من حول زلزال
المدمر في شمال غرب سوريا نتعرف معا على
ابرز المعابر الحدوديه
ان جون هنا في شمال غرب سوريا المنكوبه
حياتهم مرهونه بحبل نجاه اخير يتمثل بفتح
المعابر الحدوديه مع تركيا كي تعود الحياه
شبه طبيعيه بعد زلزال قضى على البشر
والحجر
لكن ما هي اهم المعابر الحدوديه بين سوريا
وتركيا وايها يعمل ليكون شريان حياه لاكثر
من اربعه ملايين شخص في شمال سوريا
معبر باب الهوى هو حاليا المعبر الرسمي
الوحيد في شمال ادلب لعبور المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سوريا بموجب قرار مجلس
الامن الدولي تسيطر عليه المعارضه السوريه
معبر باب السلامه في منطقه اعزاز شمال حلب
تسيطر عليه فصائل المعارضه السوريه معبر
جرابلس في ريف حلب تسيطر عليه فصائل
المعارضه السوريه ايضا
دوليا المنظمات الامميه طالبت النظام
السوري بتسهيل مرور المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه من دون قيد او شرط اما مجلس
الامن فسيعقد الاسبوع المقبل جلسه لمناقشه
امكانيه السماح للامم المتحده بارسال
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر اكثر من
معبر حدودي
بدوره النظام السوري اعلن موافقته على
ايصال مساعدات للمناطق المتضرره الخارجه
عن سيطرته وسط تردد تركي بعد ان قالت
انقره انها تدرس قرارها محاسن حداره
العربيه
بلغت الحمله الشعبيه السعوديه لايقافه
مانكوبي زلزال سوريا وتركيا اكثر من 271
مليون ريال حتى الان في وقت عبرت احدى
عشره شاحنه من المساعده السعوديه الى
الداخل السوري عبر منفذ باب الحمام
الحدودي وتبلغ حموله الشاحنات من
المساعدات واربعه اطنان تشمل مساعدات
اغاثيه ودواء وغذائيه وسيتم توزيعها في
المناطق الاكثر تضررا في شمال غرب سوريا
من هنا من الحدود السوريه التركيه حيث
دخلت عبر منفذ باب الحمام مساعدات سعوديه
اغاثيه محمله بمئه واربعه اطنان من كافه
انواع هذه المساعدات التي ستدخل الى داخل
سوريا تحديدا الى المناطق الاكثر ضررا
وهنا نتحدث عن مناطق شمال غربي سوريا عبر
هذه المساعدات التي دخلت نحن نتواجد الان
في الجانب السوري من هذا
المنفذ حيث دخلت فعليا هذه الشاحنات التي
سيتم توزيعها على اقرب منطقه
تعرضت لاكثر ضرر من هذا
الزلزال وجراء هذا الزلزال وهنا نشاهد
اداره جمرك باب الحمام والعلم السوري في
هذا في هذه السياره في هذا المكان المحاذي
او في بدايه هذا المكان في الاراضي
السوريه في الحقيقه عبر
معاهد السوري الذي سيبدا بتوزيع هذه
المساعدات مباشره بعد ان دخلت الاحد عشره
شاحنه محمله بكافه انواع هذه المساعدات
قال بان هذه المساعدات ستوزع في مناطق
شمال غربيه سوريا وتحديدا على اكثر من ما
يقارب اثنين وعشرين منطقه تعرضت لضرر كبير
جدا جراءه هذا الزلزال وهذه المساعدات
اختير هذا المنفذ لها لان هذا المنفذ هو
الاقرب لهذه
المناطق المتضرره جراء هذا الزلزال كما
قال بان هذه المساعدات هي الاولى من نوعها
الدوليه التي تدخل الى سوريا بعد ان ضربها
الزلزال قبل سته ايام عبد المحسن الحربي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث منفذ باب الحمام
السوري وصل فريق انقاذ ايطالي الى العاصمه
اللبنانيه بيروت في طريقه لمناطق سيطره
النظام السوري لاغافه للاغاثه من الزلزال
هو يعد الفريق الايطالي اول فريق او
للاغاثه ارسال الى المناطق المتضرره في
سوريا للمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
يتجه ليكون احد اعتى الزلازل في القرن
الحالي وسط تحذيرات دوريه من ان اثاره قد
تستمر لسنوات خاصه في سوريا نتيجه اثار
الحرب المدمره هي الاخرى
في هذا السياق مشاهدينا قالت المنظمه
الصحه العالميه ان زلزال الذي ضرب الاراضي
التركيه والسوريه تسبب بضرر طال سته
وعشرين مليون شخص من بينهم مليون
واربعمائه الف طفل تاثر بشده بسبب زلزال
اضافه الى 350 الف مسلم فيما اصبح اكثر من
خمسه ملايين شخص في خطر داهم وحضرت الصحه
العالميه من تضرر عشرات المستشفيات مع
ارتفاع عدد القتلى من الزلزال الى اكثر من
27,000 كما اطلقت المنظمه نداء عاجرا
طالبت فيه بقرابه ثلاثه واربعين مليون
دولار لمساعدتها على تلبيه الاحتياجات
الصحيه العاجله
الى تقديم الدعم الدولي بشكل عاجل لتلبيه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه الملحه في سوريا
وتركيا ورجح جرافيث ان يتجاوز عدد ضحايا
زلزال في تركيا وسوريا الاربعين الف قتيل
وقال جريفيت خلال مقابله صحفيه انه من
الصعب للغايه اعطاء تقدير دقيق لان
الانقاض لم يتم ازالتها بعد لكنه يعتقد ان
عدد القتل سيتضاعف او يزيد مع تواصل
عمليات ازاحه الركام والدمر
من الصعب للغايه اعطائه تقدير دقيق لان
الانقاذ لم يتم ازالتها بعد لكنني متاكد
من ان عدد القتلى سيتضاعف او يزيد
عمليات الانقاذ وثقت للحظات المؤثره
مشاهد الطفله التي حمت راس اخيها حظيت
بتعاطف كبير
الطفلان الشقيقان ناجيان من الكارثه
لكنهما انضم الى الاف الايتام الذين خلفهم
الزلزال جينان تبلغ خمسه سنوات فيما لم
يتجاوز عمره شقيقها عبده 11 شهرا اصيب
كلاهما بالعديد من الجروح
ظلام محاصرين تحت انقاذ منزلهما لمده
يومين
اقارب جنان احتفوا بها ونصبوها اميره
احد الاقارب تطوع للاعتناء بالشقيقين
الله شافانا يعني
عبده وجنان تحت رحمه رب العالمين
مشاهدينا نواصل معكم تغطيه لزلزال لكن
نتوقفوا امام بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات
اخرى في اخبارنا الدولي المتفرقه
اعلنتاجون الامريكيه رصدا خلل في اجهزه
الرادار وعدم العثور على اي جسم طائر فوق
ولايه مونتانا امس السبت وذلك بعد ارسال
طائره مقاتله للتحقق كما اكدت قياده
الدفاع الجوي لامريكا الشماليه نوراد انها
ارسلت طائرات المقاتله للتحقق مشيره الى
ان الطائرات لم ترصد اي شيء يرتبط باشارات
الرادار وانها ستواصل مراقبه الوضع وياتي
اعلان البنتا بعد ساعات من اعلان كندا
اسقاط مقاتله امريكيه لاسم بخصائص مجهوله
فوق اقليم يكون الكندي دون تحديد ما اذا
كان الامر يتعلق بمنقاد جديد
اكد حاكم مدينه الخارجيه الاوكرانيه سقوط
ثلاثه صواريخ روسيه على منشات للبنيه
التحتيه في المدينه مضيفا في بيان الله
ونشر على تطبيق تيليجرام ان الجيش الروسي
استخدم صواريخ من طراز اس 300 في الهجوم
فيما لم تحدد السلطات حتى الان عدد
الضحايا وحجم الدمار الا ان مصادر
اوكرانيه اكد التضرر محطه لتوليد الطاقه
الكهربائيه ما تسبب في اصابه ثمانيه اشخاص
في حصيله الاوليه في غضون ذلك قال قائد
الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقيم دفاعات على طول خط المواجهه في
دنيسكي لما في ذلك بلده بخموت المحاصره
وذلك مع احتدام اعنف المعارك لسيطره على
مدينتي
اصدر رئيس الاوكراني مرسوما باقاله
رسلاندو جوبا من منصب نائب قائد الحرس
الوطني ووفقا للمرسوم الموجز صادر عن مكتب
الرئاسه لم تذكر اسباب هذا القرار لكن قال
ان مسائله لتطهير الحكومه مستمره وقالت
السلطات الاوكرانيه عشرات المسؤولين في
الاسابيع الماضيه وفتحت تحقيقات في اطار
حمله واسعه النطاق في المخالفات ويقول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان التصدي الفساد من
المطالب اللازمه قبل انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الكتله المكونه من سبع وعشرين دوله
اجرت القوات الاوكرانيه تدريبات عسكريه
على الحدود البيلاروسيه واجريت هذه
المناورات العسكريه بمنطقه ريفين تحديدا
والتي تقع شمال غرب البلاد على الحدود مع
بيلاروسيا حليفه موسكو تجدر الاشاره ايضا
الى ان الجيش الروسي كان قد اجرى مناورات
عسكريه في بيلاروسيا قبل اشهر قليله
يعتبرت المتحدثه الرسمي باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان عمليه التحويل الى
اوكرانيا اخرى ليست مستمره فحسب ولكنها
تكتسب زخما
ان عمليه تحويل مولدوفا وهي دوله ذات
سياده لها تقاليدها واهدافها الى اوكرانيا
اخرى ليست مستمره فحسب ولكنها تكتسب زخما
في الصحافه المولدوفيه تتم مناقشه مساله
جدول الحفاظ على الاثار السوفيتيه بشكل
علني سياسه تمجيد المتواطئين مع النازيين
مستمره في بريطانيا اعتقل 15 شخصا تتراوح
اعمارهم بين 13
و54 عاما بعد تظاهرات عنيفه امام فندق قرب
مدينه ليفربول
طالبي لجوء ما يظهر التوتر السائد في
المملكه المتحده على خلفيه مساله استقبال
المهاجرين وتحدثت الشرطه المحليه عن تسجيل
اصابه في صفوف عناصرها بعد ان اشعر بعض
الاشخاص الراف الاستقبال اللاجئين ان نرى
في مركبه للشرطه ما ادى الى تطبيق حظر
التجمعات في المنطقه لمده ثمان واربعين
ساعه
مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره بعد قليل
متابع طيبه